merci d'être fidèle à ce rendez-vous
d'information sur TVfil 78 le journal du
lundi au vendredi 18h pour la première
diffusion et dans l'actualité de ce 10
octobre 2014 les étudiants versaillais
logé dans un monument historique
l'Orangerie réalisée par l'architecte
Louis XIV réhabilité en résidence
étudiante l'inauguration vient d'avoir
lieu ce matin le club d'onologie de
voisin le bretonne remporte la Coupe de
France des clubs d'onologie devant
Toulouse Paris et Bordeaux invité Pascal
Piednoir pierre Dominique Ray membre de
cette équipe victorieuse et comme chaque
vendredi retour en seconde partie du
journal sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans les evelines du meeting de Nicolas
Sarkozi à véisi à la célébration de l'ï
à saint-cier l'école et à Fontenel
fleuy une nouvelle résidence étudiante
donc à Versailles nous allons en parler
à présence ce vendredi a été inauguré
l'Orangerie dans un bâtiment classé
monument historique se trouve désormais
40 logements type T1 et T2 et point
innovant l'opération a été financée en
prêt locatif social réalisé grâce au
prêt d'Action Logement et de la caisse
et dépôts et consignation les
explication sur une opération qui fait à
peu près une douzaine de millions comme
ça vous avez un financement qui est
apporté par un prêt vous avez ensuite un
volet absolument important de subvention
le plus gros contributeur en de
subvention a été le ministère de
l'Éducation de l'éducation nationale
versaill est une ville où il y a 4000
étudiants et qu'il y avait quasiment pas
de logement étudiant et donc on a
profité ça un peu l'ffit d'ben d'une
opération qui était menée par le
ministère qui nous a permis d'avoir une
subvention exceptionnelle de 3 millions
d'euros et ensuite la l'intercommunalité
de Versailles Grand Parc la ville de
Versailles le conseil général ont
apporté leur contribution et donc grâce
à tous ces éléments on a pu avoir un
plan de financement qui permettait de
financer une restauration nécessairement
coûteuse une très belle victoire le 20
septembre dernier pour le club
d'onologie de voisin le bretonux les
équipes du C centralfred devini qui se
sont imposés lors de la Coupe de France
et bonjour donc à Pierre Dominique r
bienvenue en plateau et à Pascal
Piednoir artisan de cette victoire
obtenue qui plusait en terre etnemi
puisque c'était dans le beaujolet il y
avait une saveur particulière la vous
imposer là-bas bah non non c'est une
très très belle région on goûte un petit
peu moins bien les vins nous
dégustateurs mais il y a des quand même
10 crus qui font euh de jolis vin de sur
Gamet voilà et nous avions un vin sur
Gamet qu'on a réussi à à découvrir mais
euh on l'a pas loger correctement déjà
pour les initiés il va falloir tout de
suite vous mettre à la page on est parti
dans le cœur de la compétition le club
enregistre en général des bons résultats
vous étiez 3e déjà l'an dernier vous
vous attendiez à l'emporter cette
fois-ci
euh c'est l'équipe à vascal qui était 3e
euh et l'année d'avant nous on était 7e
c'était déjà pas trop mal euh et
l'emporter cette fois-ci c'était c'était
jouable vous étiez venu pour ça alors on
se prépare depuis 4 ans euh donc ce qui
est intéressant c'est que une belle
victoire collective hein c'est c'est pas
du tout un titre individuel mais une
victoire collective on avait
effectivement trois tables et euh il y a
une table qui s'est le mieux illustré
mais les autres dégustateurs continuent
en envoyant des messages sur chaque vin
sur la qui qui qui
perdd ça sentait le podium faire premier
c'est un exploit ce sont des habitués
qui qui qui participai cette année euh
justement ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
reviennent il y a de l'expérience il la
majorité disons qu'on avait deux
personnes nouvelles on avait une une
femme parmi nous Sabine et puis euh B on
s'est beaucoup entraîné avant donc gros
travail on a une jolie coupe qui brille
beaucoup à côté de vous par que ça coach
qui nous a qui nous a bien bien bien
fait travailler et c'est surtout à lui
qu'on doit remercier cette coupe d'avoir
gagné cette coupe moi pour moi j'y suis
j'y suis allé en en en dilettante et
très très surpris de
d'arriver à cette victoire avec faut pas
oublier que on avait un coéquipier qui
s'appelle Jean qui s'appelle Marc Lignac
h on était un trio
et justement vous avez évoqué la
préparation il y a une petite partie
d'expérience aussi puisque vous êtes déh
habitués de la compétition on s'entraîne
deux à trois fois par semaine on goûte 6
vin à chaque soirée il y a un candide
qui nous fait goûter à l'aveugle 6 vin
soit si vin blanc si vin rouge et sur le
final même on
finissait comme dans les conditions
compétition les conditions compétition
justement comment ça se déroule c'est un
seul match il y a deux séries ça c'est
pour les grand passe sur sur toute une
matinée on a la la compétition s'est
déroulé de 9h à 13h euh on goûte mieux
le matin nous dégustateurs donc
généralement les compétitions ont lieu
le matin euh il y a une première série
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de monde tous
les gros clubs étaient là bien sûr les
champions du monde étaient là également
même une équipe italienne qui venait
mais pour se préparer pour les
championnats du monde euh là ce sont des
20 français uniquement qui ont été 20
français uniquement ouais tout à fait et
donc il y a une première série on va
relever les six meilleures tables et on
on a eu le bonheur effectivement de
sortir premier de la première série avec
8 points ça assez confortable ceci dit
on on on s'est on s'est
retourné on avait Toulouse qui est qui
est quand même le le club qui était
favori triple champion de France ouais
on était à outsider et puis les
champions du monde qui sont trè derrière
donc on sait qu'il va pas falloir et ça
s'est joué justement à pas grand-chose a
TR points d'éc à l'AR ça a été terrible
puisque
8 points d'avance sur sur la dernière
série euh on se fait remonter sur sur on
perd de trois points sur le 10e 20 10e V
on est à à Mo- 3 de Toulouse était à
l'affu justement sur ce Gamet où on le
log à fleuy à fleuri alors que c'est un
Morgon Toulouse est sur Morgon sur le
bon mésim c'est un côe de P et nous on
met l'appellation mais sur P également
mais sur l'autre versant haut du P vous
voyez comment ça se joue ça se joue à
pas grand chose il passe tris points
devant le 11e vin on repasse un point
devant donc c'est le 12e vin qui va
faire la différence et euh on récupère
deux points sur Toulouse vous avez dit
tout à l'heure pour le goûter le le vin
c'est mieux le matin pour vous pourquoi
le matin pour ceux qui ne sont pas
habitués bah on est plus on est plus
frais on est plus dispo pour les le nez
pour la bouche euh il faut être en forme
il faut pas faut pas être fatigué pour
pour faire ce genre d'épreuve parce que
ce sont tous les sens qui sont appel au
sens donc il faut que tout soit bien AFF
on est frais dispo pour on pas la
fatigue de la journée et alors qu'est-ce
qui fait la différence c'était quoi
l'atou le petit plus que vous aviez
cette année je pense c'est le groupe
c'est le groupe c'est l'envie l'envie de
collective et la décontraction parce que
moi je suis je suis arrivé décontracté
je pensais pas du tout mais avec un
t-shirt fétiche pu que vous l'avez mis
aujourd'hui le t-shirt que mon fils m'a
offert pour mon anniversaire et je l'ai
mis aujourd'hui pour t-shirt qui vous
apporté chance appé chance je rejoins
effectivement pierre sur cette
décontraction puisque pour bien se
décontracter on fait une bonne table
généralement le vendredi soir donc c'est
il y a peu de
sport où on se décontracte à table le le
vendredi soir bon on se couche pas trop
tard et puis on abuse surtout pas par
contre je peux vous assurer que quand on
est sorti de la première série en tête
avec 8 points mon ami Pier il était un
petit peu plus
contracté il y a eu un Paris je me suis
engagé le la veille au
repas j'ai dit si on arrive sur le
podium je me coupe la moustache ah bah
voilà parole et voilà et juste après la
victoire on est allé dans un autre
restaurant
et juste après le plat de résistance je
pars aux toilettes je reviens il m'avait
installé comme chez le barbier la table
l'eau chaude le rasoir la mousse à rasée
et euh en plein restaurant on s'est
occupé de monquin voilà pour célébrer
cette victoire il fallait pas vous
engager de la sorte alors ne pas aider à
la victoire en tout cas on voit il y a
cette entente et cette bonne entente qui
sans doute est certainement participé à
votre victoire le club existe depuis
quand depuis 10 ans et depuis 10 ans les
liens se sont renforcés est-ce que des
nouveaux arrivent à s'installer aussi
dans ce club est-ce qu'ilou alors la
force aussi bien sûr c'est c'est le
résultat mais c'est le le nombre de de
personnes qu'on arrive à à regrouper au
niveau du club hein il y a 105 personnes
cette saison euh sur les 105 on en
accueille 27 nouveaux et pour la
première fois cette année et c'est
important de le souligner puisque il y a
un tiers de femmes hein dans notre club
il y a plus de femmes et que d'hommes
qui nous ont rejoint et j'espère bien en
récupérer aussi sur le groupe compète
c'estd sur la préparation des euh euh
des compétitions puisque je ça porte
quoi justement en plus il y a il y a une
façon différente de participer de de à
la compétition de de goûter les vins
aussi ceil faut bien comprendre c'est
que c'est vraiment une culture partagée
en fait on a des traceurs qu'on se
récite on fait des gammes comme comme
comme des comme des musiciens comme un
pianiste et et je trouve que les femmes
sont très pertinentes et très sensibles
sur certaines clés sur certains traceurs
et d'avoir une femme dans son équipe
effectivement si elle n'a pas forcément
la grande culture de savoir
loger le sépage ou le
sol les clés nous donnent des inf
formation pour ceux qui qui ont un petit
peu plus de connaissance donc c'est
c'est surtout au niveau né et et et et
la la femme qui nous a accompagnait qui
se prénomme sabine est vraiment un
scanner et un IRM du Wrestling et le 12e
20 tout de suite je vais sur isling on a
un petit débat entre nous je dis
attention parce que le nos nos membres
de l'équipe nous envoi un petit billet
papier en disant bah nous on pense que
c'est ça et je dis il y a Sabine
derrière nous et ça arrive
la réponse qu'on allait mettre est
confirmée par Sabine donc on est
tranquille et c'est une femme qui vous a
fait faire la différence c'était la nous
a
rassuré en tout cas au MO au moins ça
vous voulez conserver ce trophée
forcément vous vous préparez déjà pour
la prochaine compétition ah bah oui bien
sûr tout ouais ouais déjà on a eu deux
entraînements cette semaine donc et puis
il y a les championnats de France
certains membres du club vont vont me
suivre maintenant au championnat de
France donc ça c'est une nouvelle
aventure aussi plus individuelle mais
avec des déplacements collectifs puis
maintenant il va falloir apprendre à la
perdre oui pour éventuellement passer la
main ce sera peut-être le a regagner
après en tout cas là jusqu'en octobre en
2015 sera exposé au central Fred devinil
pour le club deologie merci encore à
vous deux d'être venu et félicitations
donc pour cette victoire en Coupe de
France des clubs deologie merci bien
autre information aujourd'hui ceux qui
empruntent l'autoroute à 12 depuis
rocancour savent bien qu'avant de
rejoindre la jonction avec la 10 et la
11 cette autoroute s'arrête net aux
porortes de Saint-Quentin en Yveline se
transforme en National 10 ensuite
jusqu'à
un prolongement attendu par des élus des
communes traversées depuis bien
longtemps un projet un temps annoncé a
disparu à présent du schéma directeur de
la région Île-de-France un schéma voté
en juillet dernier un choix et qui ne
plaît pas à certains a commencé par le
maire de coignère il a déposé un recours
devant le Conseil d'État suivi par le
maire de trappe guimal guimalandin qui
s'associe à cette démarche pour lui le
vote du conseil régional est tout
simplement
ilégal la première raison c'est qu'il
apparaît à l'étude du dossier que la
l'égalité n'a pas été respectée en ce
qui concerne ce que l'on appelle le pter
à connaissance c'est-à-dire les
instructions que l'état donne au au
conseil régional pour établir le le le
schéma directeur en particulier ce
porter à connaissance n'a pas respecté
la décision officielle de Monsieur
Perben de prolonger l'autoroute à 12
nous sommes le seul endroit de France où
une autoroute s'arrête et puis se
traverse des villes comme ça comme si
comme si c'était naturel et donc il faut
Pr j'ai l're 12 il faut le prolonger
pour le respect des gens il faut aussi
le prolonger pour l'avenir de
SaintQuentin en iveline tout ça a été
prévu au moment où où on a conçu
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin tout ça
est resté en panne pour des raisons qui
sont inacceptables et qui sont plutôt de
l'ordre folclorique que de l'ORD de la
responsabilité républicaine il faut donc
continuer à envisager le prolongement
d'autoroute à 12 les élus doivent
maintenant s'armer de patience il faut
patienter 2 ans pour connaître l'issue
de ce recours c'est long mais pas tant
que cela pour le maire de trappe qui
rappelle que depuis
1965 ce prolongement est maintenant
attendu nous allons à présent revenir
sur l'actualité de la semaine comme
chaque vendredi les musulmans qui
viennent de célébrer la fête de l'ï
elada la fête du sacrifice du mouton
nous nous sommes rendus dans deux lieux
pour suivre cette tradition à Fontenis
lefleuri où l'association des musulmans
de saint-cière Fontenet s'était retrouvé
tout d'abord pour la prière du matin et
puis à trpe où était un installé un
abattoir mobile claire Cambier et David
charpentier pour ce
reportage une prière aux accents de fête
à fontené le fleur car samedi matin les
musulmans célébrent l'ID al Kebir la
mosquée tant attendue par la communauté
de fontené et de saint-ir n'est encore
qu'à l'état de projet c'est donc dans un
gymnase que les fidèles se sont
retrouvés ça c'est le jour le plus
important pour les musulmans c'est ce
que l'on appelle
lair littéralement c'est la grande fête
c'est-à-dire que nous avons deux grandes
fêtes considérées comme un moment moment
de festivité assez spéciale nous avons
la fête qui commémore la fin du ramadan
que nous avons célébré il y a 2 mois et
10 jours exactement et nous avons cette
grande fête qui rappelle un peu le
sacrifice d'Abraham tel qu'il a été
organisé pour célébrer le sacrifice
d'Abraham présent également dans la
culture judéo-chrétienn les musulmans
égorgent un
mouton
bien c'est pour qu'il souff regarde ilut
pas de la souffrance alors qu'il y a des
gens qui é gens
des caméras comment ça un lien direct à
l'actualité internationale car la
communauté souhaite éviter les amalgames
l'ï doit être avant tout un jour de
partage et
d'adoration après la prière direction
trappe un abattoir mobile a été installé
pour le weekend 1450 agnau y sont
sacrifiés Laï el kbir est pour nous
l'occasion d'écouler à peu près les
2/ers de notre
production on a le plaisir de voir
directement nos clients année après
année parce que ce sont les mêmes
familles qui reviennent pendant 15 jours
les musulmans des environs ont pu
choisir leurs moutons marcher au vif
aujourd'hui ils assistent au sacrifice
suivent la découpe et récupèrent la
carcasse de leur animal prête à être
cuisiné et pour veiller aux exigences
d'hygiène une dizaine de personnes de la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations est présente
cet abattoir fait l'objet d'un agrément
à la fois sanitaire et en matière
environnmentale
et donc les règles bien sont assz simple
c'est l'inspection pour les dppp
l'inspection donc des carcasses
sanitaire des
carcasses le bien-être animal bien
entendu le sacrifice de mouton passé
vient maintenant le temps du partage en
famille et vous l'avez entendu dans les
esprits des associatifs musulmans le
terrible assassinat du français Hervé
Gourdel et la décapitation annoncée
pendant la fête de l' d'un autre otage
anglais Alan ening les musulmans
insistent sur importance de ne pas faire
d'amalgame on remercie les l'État comme
toute la République la Nation toute
entière d'avoir compris qu'il ne pouvait
pas y avoir d'amalgame entre ce qui
s'est passé en Algérie ou même ailleurs
dans le monde et les musulmans dans leur
ensemble hein on ne peut pas condamner
une majorité pour l'acte d'une minorité
mais alors minorité de chez minorité euh
mais il est important quand même que la
nation musulmane que la communauté
musulmane puisse aussi s'élever contre
ces acteslà et pouvoir dire non je ne
suis pas comme ça ceci n'est pas ma
religion politique 3e réunion publique
de Nicolas Sarkozi lundi dernier à Vézy
vill coublet en campagne pour la
présidence de l'UMP l'élection interne
se déroulera le 29 novembre l'ancien
chef de l'État a profité de son unique
passage en Île-de-France pour revenir
sur les principaux sujet d'actualité
mais aussi sur les dernières affaires
judiciaires le concernant les images de
William
l si vous saviez comme ça m'a manqué
pendant 2 ans et demi quand j'entendais
ce que j'entendais et quand je voyais ce
que je voyais
de pas pouvoir m'expliquer moi-même donc
franchement plus de 1500 personnes ça le
comble pour Nicolas Sarkozi Lendi soir à
véizi l'ancien chef de l'État qui dès
les premières minutes annonce une
nouvelle fois vouloir jouer la carte de
la transparence et du changement de quoi
galvaniser des militants déjà acquis à
sa cause avant le début du meeting je
suis rentré en politique en 2012 pour
soutenir sa candidature c'est le retour
d'une icône forte de l'UMP de l'icône
peut-être la plus forte aujourd'hui et
je pense que l'UMP en a besoin dans les
temps difficiles que l'UMP traverse ce
moment et peu importe les affaires
judiciaires même si l'on apprenait un
peu plus tôt dans la journée que la
justice étudierait maintenant un
financement illégal de campagne
électorale dans l'affaire bigmion n
a-t-il pas un cabinet noir à l'Élysée
contre Monsieur Sarkozi tout le monde le
sait je pense que la presse nous a pas
beaucoup aidé non plus moi je veux que
la justice fasse son travail pour le
coup parce que j'ai été choqué comme
beaucoup de sympathisants et de
militants de ce qui s'est passé au sein
de l'UMP via cette compagnie Via cette
société big Malion donc qu'elle fasse
surtout son travail maintenant si vous
voulez me faire dire que le président
savait ou pas moi je suis sûr qu'il ne
savait pas voilà c'est ce que je crois
sincèrement sinon il serait pas là ce
soir devant tout le monde c'est évident
sur scène Nicolas Sarkozi se veut
fédérateur remerciant la responsable
départementale de l'UMP Valérie PCR de
son soutien malgré un engagement ces
derniers mois avec François Fillon et
félicitant Gérard Larché de sa victoire
au Sénat alors que partisan de la
candidature à ce poste de Jean-Pierre
rafarin fini donc les disputes internes
vous avez pas remarqué que depuis 3
semaines si B dans notre famille ça
quand
même alors certains certains
observateurs me disent c'est pas
sincère je d mais pourquoi
peut-être mais même si c'est pas sincère
c'est plus
calme difficile d'imaginer que l'homme
vise uniquement la présidence de l'UMP
de la GPA au rythme scolaire en passant
par les 35 heur les principaux sujets
nationaux et internationaux en
condamnant l'attitude de l'Europe face à
la Russie dans le dossier ukrainien son
sont abordés durant près de 2 Hees mais
quand j'ai entendu le président de la
République français dire à la télévision
qu'il a fait des contacts indirect avec
Monsieur
Poutine ça veut dire quoi moi le 8 août
2008 j'ai eu des contacts directs et
frontaux avec Monsieur
Poutine les sujets dont il a parlé
étaient des sujets assez peu militants
mais des sujets qui étaient d'un niveau
bien au-delà donc oui vous le savez je
soutiens Nicolas Sarkozi pour la petite
et la grande élection présidentielle et
je ne doute pas qu'avec le talent
l'énergie et la vision qui sont les
siennes il représentera nos couleurs en
2017 on en a bien besoin tout le monde
sait que Nicolas czi pourra être chef du
monde je dire c'est un homme qui a
effectivement une compréhension même le
réseau quand il plaisante sur Poutine ou
sur sur Merkel on sait il a une
reconnaissance mondiale donc bien
entendu demain on aurait un chef comme
cela en France a tous les espoirs les
capitaux reviendront les talents
reviendront voilà ça redonne courage ça
redonne confiance par rapport à Monsieur
Holland qui qui est désespérant après
véizi Nicolas Sarkozi se rend à Toulouse
aucun autre passage n'est prévu dans les
ivelines avant le scrutin interne du 29
novembre et pour commenter ce retour de
Nicolas Sarkozi je recevais mardi soir
dans le 78 politique Aurore berger chef
de fil de l'opposition à manilé am
conseillère politique à l'UMP membre de
l'équipe de campagne de l'ancien chef de
l'État qui souhaite donc retrouver la
présidence de sa formation politique
elle revenait en plateau sur le retour
jugé par certains difficiles en raison
notamment des affaires judiciaires
retour réussci ou difficile ou raté pour
Nicolas Sarkozi pour l'instant c'est ce
qu'on entend à gauche à droite d'aurs
qu'on entend c'est ce qu'on entend c'est
ce que les éditorialistes disent en se
basant en se basant aussi sur certains
sondages la majorité des Français ne
sont pas forcément tous favorables au
retour de Nicolas Sarkozi il y a eu la
déclaration de soutien de Jacques Chirac
pour 2017 déjà un la Jupé tout ne marche
pas super bien non plus bah qu'est-ce
que je vois moi je voisardch qui
remporte le Sénat le favori de Nicolas
Sarkozi c'était Jean-Pierre rafarin
qu'est-ce que je vois moi je vois que
Gérard Larché hier a accueilli Nicolas
Sarkozi dans les ivelines et qu'il était
enthousiaste à l'idée de l'accueillir
quce que je vois que la salle était
pleine à craquer vous l'avez constaté
vous-même et qu'en effet on a eu du mal
à pouvoir malheureusement faire rentrer
tout le monde tant il y avait de gens
qui avaient envie de le revoir donc il y
a un enthousiastme il a un enthousiaste
qui s'est confirmé alanberçard dans le
Nord qui s'est confirmé à 3 dans l'au
qui se confirme dans leses qui se
confirmera jeudi à Toulouse donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un enthousiasme clair
pour la candidature de Nicolas Sarkozi
ça veut dire aussi que comme il l'a dit
un peu ironiquement les décibels se sont
calmés à l'UMP depuis qu'il est revenu
parce que enfin il y a une autorité il y
a un chef il y a une direction et
étonnamment du coup ça a calmé un
certain nombre d'ardeur ou un certain
nombre de perturbateurs qui finalement
s'accommodai d'une situation où l'UMP
était un peu en délicatesse ou en
faiblesse donc moi je vois un
enthousiasme évident de la part des
militants qui a avait envie de ce retour
qu' l' attendait et je pense qu'il se
confirmera de manière très forte le 29
novembre prochain quand nous voterons et
puis après il faut entamer une longue
route qui est celle déjà de la
reconstruction et de la recomposition de
notre famille politique émission à
revoir en intégralité sur notre site
internet politique toujours le nouveau
numéro de café politique découvrir ce
weekend sur notre antenne invité Alain
agage le maire PCF de laavrière il
reviendra dimanche à 19h30 sur les
principaux dossiers qui concernent sa
ville et sur son parcours également
voici un extrait
au début de votre réponse vous avez
évoqué la couleur politique c'est
important de garder la couleur politique
dans la commune aujourd'hui ça veut dire
quoi être communiste justement bah être
communiste c'est je pense que c'est ce
ne plus s'éloigner des idées de justice
sociale des idées de de développement
pour l'humain c'est c'est finalement
revenir à ces valeurs fondamentales qui
nous manquent tant qui nous manque
tempant celle de la place de l'homme la
place de de la démocratie effectivement
la part participation la citoyenneté et
puis la place du rapport aux éléments
fondamentaux de la vie c'est-à-dire le
travail
l'amitié la construction commune de de
l'avenir et donc ce sont des des valeurs
c'est un système de valeurs après
derrière il y a des partis des
organisations on peut être d'accord ou
pas d'accord sur la totalité mais je
crois que l'esprit effectivement de
vouloir une société meilleure une
société plus juste reste d'actualité
c'estuve mais non mais non c'est pas du
ça pe sappliquer ça peut se tradu
bien sûr bien sûr extrait du café
politique à découvrir en intégralité ce
weekend on en revient à l'actualité
depuis lundi le seul ara national
d'île-de-fance est donc en vente une
décision du conseil général qui peut
surprendre lorsque l'on sait que le
département des ivelines compte le plus
grand nombre de licenciés d'équitation
en France reportage sur ce Hara des
brevvières de yolen Torz le hara
national des brevvières est à vendre le
Conseil général des Yvelines
propriétaire de ce terrain de plus de 40
hectares ne ne souhaite plus le
conserver pour le président du comité
régional d'équitation d'Île-de-France
c'est la stupéfaction bah la surprise
elle est totale parce que il est pas
question pour nous d'ailleurs de quitter
On va faire en sorte de convaincre
Pierre Bédier que c'est c'est ce serait
une erreur la raison évoquée par Pierre
Bédier président du conseil général des
contraintes budgétaires trop importantes
et des priorités qui sont ailleurs une
décision ferme qui remet en question la
création d'un parc équestre national
un projet pour lesquel les élus du
département avaient voté une subvention
de 400000 € il y a un an en 2006 pierre
bé avait même impulsé la mission cheval
avant de faire machine arrière cette
année c'est à contrario de la politique
qui avait été engagé il y a 7 ans donc
on a travaillé pour justement faire de
de ce site le la maison du cheval
regroupant toutes les composantes de la
filière cheval c'est-à-dire l'élevage
c'est-à-dire la la commercialisation et
cetera la formation les 15
fonctionnaires que compte le ara
national espèrent voir le futur parc
équestre aboutir mais pour le moment
l'heure est à l'incertitude on est dans
l'attente voilà on a envie que qu'on ait
une position claire on a envie de voir
parce que pour continuer et pour avancer
et faire des actions dans le futur il
faut qu'on sache où on va et là on
aimerait avoir une position claire et
savoir voilà qu'est-ce qu'on va devenir
et est ce qu'on va faire plus tard le
terrain aurait été estimé à plus de 2
million d'euros parmi les éventuels
repreneur le président du comité
régional j'ai une proposition mais là je
suis dans une phase négociation je pense
aboutir de façon raisonnable voilà ouais
d'accord et c'est prévu pour quand le
plus vite
possible le Conseil général des Yvelines
de son côté n'a pas donné suite à nos
demandes d'interview le département des
Yvelines reste le plus cavalier de
France avec 159 centres équestres et
licencier le journal revient lundi d 18h
pour une nouvelle édition nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité locale je vous
souhaite un très bon
weekend